when's the last time you went to church
i went to church and i was [ __ ] a guy
in the back view honestly almost been
there i had some hot church leaders um i
actually went to church for a long time
you know i was a church leader you were
a church leader
the dichotomy i was like on mali on
saturday like leading people to god on
sunday it was that's not true
you were a church leader i really was i
was a christian church well what
happened to you no no nothing i was just
this bad that i i was just it was i
could dial it back it was something to
do well it was just something i mean i
am religious it's
messed with god lady
no i love him love that guy that doesn't
make you not religious she can believe
in whatever she wants i'm super
religious just you know i i do a lot of
i don't know
i don't know if he's going to let me
into heaven i might show up up there and
he's gonna be like [ __ ] the bible is
just an interpretation and her
interpretation is a lot looser than
yours a lot looser
yeah no it makes no sense when i tell
anyone that i love god they're like but
as a church leader who who are these
followers
i'm sure she's got followers by leading
to god um i mean it was like youth group
it wasn't anything too seriously i
almost think more of being a church
leader is just like handing out pizza
and like singing like our god is greater
you know just like
just vibing being good you know looking
after people uh praying for people let
me just say this you don't have to
continue doing the crazy stuff you're
doing for people that are like you
they're gonna like no trust me i it's
actually more so that i will like you
like jackie i don't think she's doing
crazy stuff i think that i think she's
being herself that's what i think i
don't think i'm doing well that's got to
stop you why why you want to know
something this is what i like about her
and don't say i'm going to cry and thank
you
this is what i found intriguing because
in in looking through the stuff before
you showed up today
you know there are
i just thought that you were incredibly
authentic and even though in most
people's books that would be wild and
it's crazy and look what she's doing i
think a lot of people
probably have those thoughts want to do
those things want to be those places
wanna but they don't because they're so
concerned about how they'll be perceived
and
like keeping their jobs keeping their
friends uh
having their parents uh be proud or
whatever to be don't have any of those
which makes me feel bad for you no no no
no you're just joking like i said i'm
gonna do i feel bad no like i'm like but
they're the best in the world like my
last christmas with them was like
amazing but you're not really adopted no
not not on paper but i mean like they've
been my mom and dad since as long as i
can remember you call them do you call
them you have siblings i talk to them
like every day no i'm an only child but
again my best friend amari he has
siblings so they're like my uh wait a
minute amari's not the same guy that
with the throuple no that's my son very
much imagine i'm dating my brother let
me know
that's monson but to be fair with you i
mean i never think that i'm doing
anything for validation i think if
anything if i cared what people think
thought and wanted validation i would
dial it back but don't you think that
there's a moral compass that we all have
within us for sure but i mean but mine's
looser for sure okay but so that you
need to kind of fine-tune that compass
that's your opinion that's your opinion
no it's a moral compass it's one that
isn't if she's not hurting but let me
tell you something so here's the moral
compass i'll just give you a person like
i know i want to treat people right so
here's the thing if you want to talk
about the church or even you know the
temple or whatever the temple no but
whenever everybody has their you know
there are there are priests that take a
vow of celibacy now you consider
yourself one of those
no i didn't you just
yeah you [ __ ] that one up
no i'm just kidding i mean for me my
moral compass lies on being a good
person taking care of the people around
me being a good friend you know being
someone people being a good human being
yeah like that's the goal i mean
obviously we all make mistakes but i i
try to really treat people with but how
many kindness how many people externally
are doing and practicing what you
believe no no no no
so the point is isn't it more important
to be a good human being and it doesn't
matter and the fact that she's you know
do you like puppies
you know no i don't know no but you look
at him and he's talking to me about
moral compass
no but i had a little puppy i loved i
had a little puppy my wife bought a
little puppy i feel like this story's
gonna end really bad no it was really
good it didn't die okay
no you went in the bed i had a little
puppy and every time we let the puppy
out of the house the puppy [ __ ]
everything the puppy [ __ ] every
[ __ ] puppy cat every stuffed animal
it [ __ ] things and then it would bite
things and then we'd eat all our [ __ ] it
would [ __ ] all over the house but it was
the most
adorable
she knows the puppy i'm talking about
but it was the best puppy it was just a
good puppy i resonate with the puppy but
what i'm saying is ultimately i'm not
saying you i'm not sure if you've never
[ __ ] in my living room have you ever if
you were let me just add you to a list
no no no i'm not judging what i am
saying is i'm
contrasting your comment earlier i
appreciate the challenge i do but i
think that i'm very secure in who i am
as a person and i definitely think with
what i do online you have to i mean at
least me i'm definitely you're secure as
a person but you won't you won't mess
your hair with the headsets oh [ __ ] no
[Music]
you